elle est téméraire
bah entreprenons
je suivis règne donc j'ai
je suis marié j'ai deux grands garçons
et je vis à l'arrivée à saint louis et
travaille à l'arrivée à saint louis avec
une association pour gérer des
prestations pédagogiques pour les écoles
surtout pour les écoles le matin avant
de que les enfants arrivent c'est très
calme
on entend les oiseaux on entend le poney
ou entendre les canards les chèvres mais
dans deux heures on va attendre à les
rires des enfants
ce projet je pense que c'est un petit
peu un aboutissement d'un parcours
professionnel au départ au niveau du
parcours pour moi c'était bon comme
j'étais éducatrice spécialisée
je travaillais donc avec les enfants et
en vers la quarantaine j'ai voulu allier
deux choses qui me tenait à coeur et
d'entrée très militante dans l'âme
j'avais par rapport à mes convictions
pouvoir les développer en mettant en
place vraiment quelque chose qui
correspond au fond de moi ce que j'avais
vraiment envie et allié le travail
éducation à l'environnement avec les
enfants john tu es là bonjour a en fait
connu et bien moi je suis là vous êtes
dans mon atelier parce que je suis
artiste plasticien donc voilà je
praticien la ferme castille siens à la
ferme je suis agriculteur pour une fois
là on est dans une ferme où le l'homme
n'est pas l'agriculteur premiers mois je
suis second à la ferme puisque j'ai un
autre métier mais ma femme voilà dirige
de main de maître parce que elle a ce
côté altruiste ou llm fédérer les gens
elle aime s'occuper des gens elle aime
faire du lien social
ce rapport nous on a peut-être classe a
et ce matin il va avoir des enfants
autistes qui vont être là donc tout
compte fait 24 et amant si c'est eux qui
font à babe un serment qui aura le petit
groupe d'enfants autistes
quand jean boesch quelqu'un au ca de la
structure c'est vrai que en premier je
regarde pas le diplôme le diplôme pomas
et par rapport à l'animateur c'est
secondaire
ce que je vais regarder ce qu'on nous
l'a besoin c'est d'abord du savoir être
et le savoir être
ça se décrète pas pour mener une équipe
c'est pas toujours évident c'est pour ça
j'avais fait le choix donc d'aller à
l'iae pour me former
mais j'avais choisi donc management
association pour me donner des outils
pour aller au delà
voilà donc ça donne un petit peu un
petit point de vue jeunes et d'anciens
on est vraiment une vraie cuvette niveau
géographique
là on comprend pourquoi ça s'appelle le
cirque selon les dans l'entrée du cirque
de cilaos
donc du coup il ya des deux côtés de les
deux rangs par là qui forment cette
cuvette lula les enfants arrivent donc
je vais décembre
vous fait à base sur les tables tout
puis on vient là c'est le four à bois
on essaie de personnes donc le principe
c'est que chaque classe il ya un
animateur n'a eu huit ateliers tous les
ateliers touche quand même elle le pivot
c'est l'éducation à l'environnement
mais tous touchent par rapport à où
l'animal le végétal mais tout est en
lien avec l'éducation l'environnement
bonjour baujot de tout alors alors voila
moi je suis je suis mireille c'est moi
ce matin d'après toi pourquoi tu es
sensibiliser comme ça ça devient doute
toi ben c'est je pense est une
continuité de haut niveau de
l'expérience tant la vie par rapport à
un cheminement professionnel par rapport
le travail avec des enfants par rapport
des questionnements personnels et donc
un moment on arrive à un espèce de
recentrage je peux dire qu'est ce qui
est essentiel et c'est pas évident
d'être le plus dépouillé possible et de
faire bien en étant plus dépouillé en
étant voilà donc ça c'est c'est un
challenge de tous les jours
si vous faites trop de bruit je fais
criquets et vous y répondez à quai
riquet
est-ce que vous avez ogier commencé
parce qu'une à la grèce sur ses plus
mauvais que ça et de semoule ou pas
comment on appelle la maman cochons les
enfants une truie mis une autre 8t
ensemble
au début des années 2000 c'est vrai
qu'il n'y avait pas de faire pédala
réunion
bon moi j'en avais vu en métropole et
j'ai trouvé que mon pain par rapport le
modèle il fallait s'en inspirer pour
pouvoir en créer à la réunion qu'est ce
qu'on a comme richesse au niveau
patrimoine quand on arrive sur ce site
on a tout un pack même quand on n'a rien
fait il ya déjà un patrimoine au niveau
niveau des oiseaux au niveau de la
géologie au niveau des insectes au
niveau des arbres nains tout un
patrimoine et à partir de ce patrimoine
qu'est ce que pour construire donc moi
ce que j'appelle de conséquence
contextualiser la pédagogie est ce que
pouvait faire look et de la poule pour
moi mais combien d'animaux ou en tout
comme écoulée canal et d'un don doit
bien avoir les cochons tout 300 de ce
nom n'a pas envie de tout chez nous et
les doux il a des cas ce qu'il a sur le
dos lui est bien des poils il a un
pelage
c'est un métier qui demande quand même
de la disponibilité qui demande de
couper la turquie demande de l'ecoute
demande en capacité aussi me sens de
partage des choses et qui laisse la
place à l'autre aussi
ben et qu'ils allaient super avec
mireille ouais mais pas ces moments
cette capacité-là 2
pouvoir ont serré mener tout en même
temps en laissant aussi en laissant les
ans est responsable on les sent aussi
les personnes qui l'ont emmené aussi
quoi cette année c'est une année
particulière pour nous c'est une année
charnière et on a dit on a mis cette
année sous le signe de la qualité donc
donc pour faire la qualité on va le
décliner en plusieurs objectifs et on va
mettre en place aussi des supports pour
arriver à cette qualité avec la ferme
mince et son projet de départ et on a
monté une association et petits milles 1
bis qui du coup gère tout l'aspect
accueil pédagogique
récemment l'association salangane plus
pouvoir une pédagogie alternative on
peut diagou jean nouvel
on mange ici c'est petit il est bien par
rapport à ce que la réunion
peu peut nous donner aujourd'hui moi
j'espère que dans les générations
futures
ils profiteront autant que nous on a
profité nous on aimerait bien au niveau
de la flotte fed ainsi qu elle puisse
devenir ce qu'on appelle un centre de
ressources un centre de ressources
pédagogiques pour les fermes
pédagogiques de la réunion c'est à dire
que qu'on puisse disposer d'un fonds
documentaire mais aussi qu'on puisse
faire de la formation qu'on puisse bien
formés par pour les outils pédagogiques
je pense qu'on a c'est aujourd'hui
d'antériorité on a la capacité sein de
nos animateurs pour qu'on puisse
transmettre et pour que tout en un
projet comme ça parce que j'ai envie que
les choses changent
alors voilà doit tout le temps je sais
je suis toujours assez pas les gens qui
sont autour de moi des fois je suis un
peu à ça à 200 à l'heure
et en fin de compte j'ai envie que de
changer
des petites choses pour la réunion
poinot peu nos enfants et j'ai envie que
ça change
le